et là tout le monde s'est excusé
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur probably
archerie un jeu que vous m'avez
conseiller en masse en masse en masse
depuis deux semaines parce qu'il est
sorti il ya un put your plus de semaine
il me semble c'est parti j'ai absolument
jamais je ne sais absolument pas
quel mode prendre target practice il
paraît que c'est bien pour apprendre à
jouer au hockey donc ça c'est pour
bouger tout le bras est ce que ce jeu ne
serait pas en fait un simulateur d'ordre
le matin à stonewall inn et chats non
mais c'est carrément impossible quoi
faut vraiment qu'ils arrêtent les jeux
comme ça c'est plus possible tout far
from string to knock
je comprends rien c'est dégueulasse à
notre chère madame laissez ou au tir et
à les nier
je veux me gratter le bras avec cette
flèche mais la flèche essuie-glaces
voilà l'abonnement extrême du temps je
comprends rien regardez auger qui leur
[ __ ] de boyaux ou quoi ces cas-là beau
diable fléche orchestra à red stéphanie
c'est trop drôle hein ok donc ça c'est
pau où là on passe une branche
égyptienne ans chez jeep sienne tain ça
fait carrément travesti quoi ah mais non
il n'est pas il est pas fort du string
[ __ ] veut nommer mec mais c'est
impossible quoi au j'adore ce bruit oui
regardez j'ai réussi tout le monde
regarde
atlanta miss à stéphanie attendait
puisque du coucher plutôt que j'ai fait
c'est un truc comme ça tout va bien cet
arc prospère juste notre main tu vois
bien un septet n'avait pas remarqué non
mais attends mais mettez le but ce n'est
pas de mettre la flèche dans l'oeil bien
évidemment à opio on peut jouer au bras
de fer voilà si on ajoute à ça c'est
l'abandon
c'est ça la bonne d'une flèche
j'abandonne je note mais je suis sûre
cette [ __ ] de cordes mais je suis
dessus regarde mon gars on dirait même
que tu veux la gratter l'accord regarde
bien oui j'espère que ça te fait du bien
un petit massage de cordes
bon bah l'entraînement est finie un
composé vous on va pouvoir passer à des
trucs sérieux the berserk à cheveux tout
ce que c'est round 1 watts merde merde
mon coeur bat aurait il ya un homme tout
nu qui ne compte qu avec une épée est ce
qu est ce que vous pensez sincèrement
que je réussis alouettes une flèche à
laymont car l'homme body builder avec
une pomme à la place de la tête c'est ça
qui nous poursuivaient à l'instant
regardez comment ils arrivent vite mais
[ __ ] apprend la flèche mais lui dessus
mais non invasif du mac ou de flèches
comme ça dès qu'il arrive on met bien la
flèche vers voilà la pomme alors qu'il
s'approche dessus tout seul est ce qu'on
peut dire que c'est un fail l'homme qui
fait de la perceuse samara c'est ce que
firent un mais non mon gars et non
chrétiens
on va mettre juste un petit retour sur
image du personnage qu'on joue et voilà
est ce que c'est vraiment un personnage
est ce que de là on comprend pourquoi je
n'arrive pas à tirer ne serait-ce qu'une
flèche dans ce [ __ ] de mec qui a une
pub je sais pas c'est aussi ridicule que
c'était jimmy notre eau qui nous cours
et eu avec une épée quoi je propose de
retourner au menu et d'éventuellement
trouver un mode à un petit peu plus
simple ah [ __ ] mais c'est ce qui me
déconcentrer les abords de ce tome beau
gosse là bas au fond aussi
c'est absolument faux tout à l'heure
j'ai réussi à tirer des flèches mais
même si c'était sur les pigeons 1
c'était quand même incroyable
attendez je m'étonne oh oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] ce que tout le monde a entendu le
bruit de sanglier à ça vaut plus que tu
es dans une pomme sur une pomme sur la
corde body builder ça ça me donne envie
de danser la non non est ce que cet
homme m'a vraiment une main ou une
preuve et on retrouve encore ces fameux
trait de crayon à papier à la place des
poils de bras arrêté de tenter de vous
qualifier au crayon de papier
s'il vous plaît ça ne marche pas alors
arrêté at st joseph in je te jure tu vas
pas me croire il avait une pomme à la
place de la tête quoi ah bah tu vois là
on a une posture parfaite de l'archet à
moi je suis chef de faux coup moi dans
avengers
ok tu prends pas de quoi fouetter
croiser les deux perles marché là en
plus c'est du fait qu'il n'a même pas la
flèche entre les deux doigts il ya la
flèche en fait planter dans son index
voilà c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on
n'arrive pas à tirer je veux tu bregi
mon arc
je veux tu que tu sois à tous brillants
allez je te lustres aurait jusqu'à
l'infini
[ __ ] puis le métro de crème solaire
sur ses bras à quoi cet homme j'ai envie
de lui lancer à la main non l'or suit la
flèche de ce que je sais que tu en es
capable non joséphine je suis pas
capable si
je sais qu'on est capable et le dis
allez vas-y s'évertue à les feuilleter
défi aux non on n'en faut que le sauver
mais regardez comment la barre de vie
mais [ __ ] mais c'est pas possible ça
ménard le mec à l'aide [ __ ] d'arc tu
vas rentrer dans le temps à moi j'étais
jamais là jamais tenté de sauver
quiconque vous êtes en état
d'arrestation n'avait pas réussi à
sauver mais c'est un possible et vieux
jeu je comprends pas je le veux
ah ah ok un peu 4 ok je suis un mec qui
lie à un ballon elle passe de la tête
aucun sens c'est plutôt un peu ridicule
du monde clickair faut vider au tutorial
à bâle ça va alors je pense que ça va
mieux aller c'est scandaleux quoi c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait juste avant
c'est exactement ça ok mais là je suis
d'une mauvaise foi extrême bonté alors
voilà en mon gars oh oui mon gars oh oui
oh oui oh c'est comme ça je te remercie
oh c'était sangliers attendait mais
s'est refusée ou quoi il faut vraiment
le maître méga bakwa base de comme ça un
[ __ ] on l'aurait eu la mauvaise foi
extrême oh [ __ ]
je vais tenter l'impossible aujourd'hui
est un grand jour
on va tenter de se faire le berserk
c'est parti aucune pitié et non c'est
bon cette fois à regarder il m'a pas
nous avoir
voilà il nous a pas eu il ya quand même
un mode multijoueur moi je veux voir la
mode multijoueur à ya aucun serveur ocs
monga l'amusement extrême
je m'attendais mais les gars à la fois
de carreman superman pour viser un truc
qui bouge que et pourquoi sept vols à
regarder le et nous narguent quoi ils
nous narguent si l'offre avait été
remplacé par ça on aurait ressenti la
même chose je suis l'homme qui tire à
l'arc et attention cette flèche est pour
toi dos dans ton cul pour moi voilà les
gens c'est déjà fin de cette petite
vidéo sur probably archerie et bien
évidemment comme ça on l'a dit ce mec
est probablement un marché moi je pense
plutôt que c'est un artisan boulanger
qui s'est mis au tir à l'arc depuis deux
minutes
en tout cas j'espère que cette vidéo
vous en rappelez sans doute c'est une
nouvelle vidéo chat du monde pis je dois
mourir quoi ce fleuve dont mais
frustrant de la gorge
non c'est pas moi
dès que je n'ai pas fait d'éclat
mais bien fort
les gars
pour andré j'aime pas trop denses et
puisque j'ai l'impression que tout le
monde me regarde et que je suis mais